si vous êtes désormais comédien fait que
la grande ville et dienville choix qui
vous le dirai l'art de la comédie c'est
l'art de mentir nous allons donc faire
une interview mensonge
c'est très compliqué vous devez répondre
steevy exactement le contraire de ce que
vous pensez un accord d'accord il ya du
piège oui je sais il ya du pis comment
ça se passe avec l'udc est plutôt très
mal comment très très mal c'est la cata
tu laisseras bon il a compris le
principe pour déjà une chose
alors maintenant regarde ça va tomber la
même stevie est ce que vous avez été
obligé de coucher pour avoir le rôle
oui j'ai couché par avoir ces rollin
avec ma main droite avec qui avec ma
main droite avec sa maman et des monos
sexuelle stevie ça vous fait quoi que
des gens payent plus de 40 euros pour
venir vous voir sur la scène d'un
théâtre ça je m'en contrefous vraiment
rien à [ __ ] chacun sa bourse stevie
imaginer qu'un jour vous marier que vous
ayez des enfants et que votre fils
viennent vous voir et vous annonce qu'il
est hétérosexuel vous réagiriez comment
très mal
très mal est-ce que vous avez déjà fait
d'abord avec bourrique et stevie vue si
tu as fait la bouffe à vue de briques et
enfin en tout cas elle est à côté de moi
à michel demande qui est bourriquet
michel michel
vous expliquer qui est beau piqué alors
bourrique et c'est une petite tenue sont
fait une grosse pub us que j'ai depuis
l'âge de 6 ans
décidée au départ c'est marrant parce
qu'il est bien il est pratiquement plus
connu que moi vous riquez
va peut-être pas
alors comment va vous dis ça c'est là
c'est le truc car comment va vous sur
stv avez-vous menti au cours de cette
interview
non le mystère c'est bien ça et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux